well I would like to thank work in
Aman's that I made this wonderful
question what can we them can
to promote more equation and unity Latin
America I really think that the one of
the most wonderful ways of working unity
through cultural activities for example
if you could be asked to do something in
Latin American music
dr. American literature and have a big
summits where we can put on our
differently cultural activities together
can grow up in a movement of a cultural
identity of America we have so much
beautiful music Susan so much are they
survived maybe that would be a good idea
and we can get in nature of our culture